and the winner is apple's new 14-inch
and 16-inch macbook pros now finally
have a massive amount of graphics
performance making them actually viable
gaming laptops but the problem is that
most popular games only run on windows
and since bootcamp is no longer
supported on m1 max i will be guiding
you guys through the two best methods of
getting windows 11 on your mac so you
can start playing the games you want to
play including a full step-by-step guide
for parallel 17 to play games like
overwatch and crossover 21 to play games
like grand theft auto 5. and of course
we will be revealing the winner of our
2500
14-inch macbook pro giveaway at some
point in this video so be sure to watch
the full thing so you don't miss it
getting right into the parallel 17
installation guide head over to
parallels.com and click download free
trial and then click download once
finished open the dmg file within your
downloads folder and double click on the
icon to begin then click open and click
ok when the software agreement pops up
click accept then type in your max
password on the desktop permission
screen hit next and then click ok on all
of the prompts before clicking finish
when the m1 macbook pro screen pops up
click continue which now shows us that
we need the windows installation file to
move on to get that head to google and
type in windows insider program then
click on register just under that first
result
once there click sign in now to sign
into your microsoft account and if you
don't have one be sure to create one
once logged in it'll take you to this
page where you should see a button that
says register now so click that and go
through the registration process once
finished go back to google and type in
windows 11 on arm insider preview and
click on the first result which should
look like this you should see a blue
button showing the current windows build
click on it and click allow to begin the
download which is going to be almost 10
gigabytes in size once the download is
complete with parallel 17 open double
click on that windows 11 file in your
downloads folder then choose games only
if that's what you're using it for and
you can click customize settings before
installation if you want to do that and
then wait for the process to complete
when the configuration screen pops up
click on the hardware tab and you can
see that the cpu and memory is set to
automatic which has 5 cpu cores and 16
gigs of ram which is exactly half of
what this macbook pro has if you want
you can click manual and then set the
processors to the highest available
which is 6 and then set the memory to
the highest which is 26 on my system
then click on the lock and close the
configuration screen and click continue
at this point it's telling us that the
standard edition of parallels only
supports up to 8 gigabytes of memory so
if you want to use the full 26 you'll
need to click on this link where it
shows the benefits of the pro edition
and then click on upgrade then click on
this little checkbox for entering a
coupon code and then type in the coupon
code in the description of this video to
get 10 off the pro edition and then
click apply and go through with the
purchase now if you just want to try it
out for free click configure on this
pop-up then click the lock icon type in
your passcode or use touch id and then
set your ram back down to 8 gigabytes
then click the lock again close the
window and click continue and click ok
through all the prompts when windows is
done installing click to continue and
then at this point you can log in or
create a parallels account and now
you're finally in windows 11 and you
should be greeted with the windows
update page with it already beginning to
install updates once the updates are
finished go ahead and click to restart
windows once it restarts parallels will
continue to install tools so once they
finish restart windows once again and
now we're done you can use it like a
regular pc like for example downloading
and installing games using steam but
keep in mind that some games require
anti-cheat software so they're currently
not supported on m1 max but i went ahead
and installed the battle.net launcher so
i could download and play overwatch so
let's finally test it out but before we
get into that parallels gameplay as well
as getting into installing crossover 21
and playing games like grand theft auto
5 i do want to run a geekbench 5 cpu
test to check out the performance that
we're getting as you can see i have
geekbench drive open right here i've
actually set it to eight cores using the
pro edition as well as 26 gigs of ram so
let's run the test and there you go we
have our score and we're getting around
7 500 multi-core points which is
basically the performance of an m1
macbook pro natively in mac os but of
course this is going through a virtual
machine so you're not getting all the
performance and you also don't have
access to the full 10 cores so this is
actually very very impressive but as we
know the graphics side is going to be
much higher so let's go ahead and test
it out all right here we are in
overwatch let's go ahead and configure
the settings starting out it's in full
screen at the native res but i think
that's a little bit insane i'm gonna
switch actually to the aspect ratio of
16x10 let's bring it down let's see to
around 1080p let's do that switch the
fps to display based starting off the
graphics quality on low display
performance stats yes we want to see
that frame rate is on gpu temp let's see
if that works vram usage why not
hit apply there we go we got our fps
currently it's limited to 60 at least
here so we'll see if we can get the full
120. here we go in the practice section
because i'm waiting for a match look at
that we're getting a hundred over 100
fps right now
90 right there so it does dip down a
little bit but we have not gone below
60 not once look at that there are some
glitches though sometimes it stutters
and drop frames and now we're in a real
match with real players which is awesome
but we are getting some drop frames and
weird kind of glitchiness stuttering so
we'll see how that goes
after we get out of here whoa okay this
is weird now that i'm in here it's kind
of unplayable i don't know what's going
on
[Applause]
it's not fun so for some reason being in
an actual match is getting a lot of
glitchiness
stuttery frames it's like even over here
just not doing very well with the fps so
i've turned down the resolution a little
bit but
it kind of like cropped in
but as far as the performance it's still
pretty bad it's a stuttery mess
i'm not sure why or what's causing it i
don't have time to kind of troubleshoot
and look at what's causing the bad fps
but hopefully this will get fixed soon
and hopefully somebody
kind of takes a look at the settings and
optimizes everything and now with
parallels out of the way let's go ahead
and get into the tutorial for installing
crossover 21 but first let's go ahead
and get into our giveaway all right guys
here is max yeah and here's the backbone
thank you guys for subscribing for
commenting for watching all our videos
we've been putting our very best into
these and it's awesome to see you guys
enjoying them and we're glad to give
this 2500 macbook away to one of you
guys we still want to reach a million
for the end of the year that is our goal
so if you didn't want the macbook you
didn't subscribe help us to reach our
one minute goal we would greatly
appreciate it now right here we have a
playlist with the launch week mac videos
that we have and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna number each one from one to
seven so the first one is number one the
last one that we just posted is number
seven and we're gonna go into a random
number generator minimum one max seven
let's go ahead and pick one of those
videos and then we're going to choose a
comment from that video man ready my
heart is beating my heart is beating i'm
excited for you guys which one is it
generate
one the first video that's the one that
has the most comments right yeah it has
very first ones like 33 000 comments
check this out geez
34 000 comments guys so hopefully you
commented on this one that gives the
most people a chance to win
out of the other videos okay so what we
did is we grabbed the url for the
youtube video we're throwing it into
commentpicker.com as you can see right
here and i am checking the box that says
filter duplicate users so if somebody
spammed a bunch of comments trying to
win it's not gonna work so there you go
filter and let's click get youtube
comments all right everything's finally
loaded in and right there is the start
raffle and pick random winner button are
you ready i'm ready all right guys let's
do this
all right we're scrolling we're
scrolling choosing oh
and the winner is
matthew ceo
your name his comment says i can't
believe how fast that bend base model is
wow double exclamation marks all right
guys we found matthew online we just
messaged him and he responded so let's
do a video call
hey
we're recording right now this is your
lucky day
we're excited for you yeah so matthew we
just did our giveaway we selected a
random number the random generator thing
out of 30 thousand out of over 30 000
comments on that video you are the
winner
of the 2500
macbook pro
yes
yes
we have angelica back here too
not a scam come on
we don't do scams here at max tech thank
you for watching our videos thank you
for commenting
we appreciate it yeah it was cool seeing
your comment you said the base macbook
pro is the bin version is so powerful
but you won the unbid one so you got the
extra chorus and that's the graphics
perfect there you go
that's awesome we're so glad
yeah congratulations we're glad that you
didn't already buy one or two i mean
some people already have so this is
gonna be perfect so uh we'll get off the
call get your contact info and get that
sent right over to you man
that's awesome i'm super stoked awesome
thank you matthew
congratulations thank you very much
let's now get into how to install and
run crossover 21 as you can see right
here but since this is already set up
i'm going to grab a fresh 14 inch
macbook pro and set it up on this one
first off head over to google type in
crossover 21 download
go to their website right here enter
your name your email and then click
download trial now then head to your
downloads folder and double click on the
cross over zip file and extract it there
you go we have crossover double click to
begin the installation and then click
move to applications folder now
crossover also has a 14 day free trial
which is nice to try it out before
purchasing it so let's click try now and
there you go crossover is now downloaded
click the blue installing windows app
button type in steam there you go
continue install make sure to go through
all the prompts to download the fonts
and other things like that download the
xml parser
accept next next install
and finish and there you go the steam
setup
let's go through that very quickly boom
it's done but we're not going to click
run steam because we have a couple more
things to download within crossover
click done now click the button again
for installing an app type in
directx for modern games and then go to
select the bottle and switch to the
steam bottle that's very important click
continue
and let's install go through downloading
directx right here there you go finish
that up done and then go ahead and click
on the bottles right here right click on
the steam bottle go to settings and turn
on dxvk backend for d3d11
and there you go that's basically it for
installing crossover 21 all you do now
is run steam and then go ahead and
download all the games you want to play
but since those games take a while to
download i'm going to put this aside and
grab my 16 inch macbook pro with grand
theft auto 5 already installed so let's
go ahead and get into some gameplay but
before we begin i do want to show you
guys something destiny 2 right here
actually uses
anti-cheat and unfortunately you are not
able to play those games so you've got
to stick with the ones that don't have
that but with that said luckily we have
grand theft auto 5 so let's go ahead and
start it and this is using one of the
beta builds in order to play grand theft
auto 5 so if you're interested in
playing this you've got to go over to
the crossover website sign up to be a
beta tester and then download the latest
nightly build and then you'll be able to
play gta 5. and while this is loading i
do want to mention that i'm going to be
doing a full
gaming review
with this 16 inch m1 max 32 core gpu
macbook pro with 32 gigs of ram i'm
gonna be playing a ton of different
games using both the native mac os apps
like world of warcraft there's also
league of legends starcraft 2 diablo 2
minecraft then i've got the crossover
titles like the witcher 3 of course this
game then i've got parallels i'm gonna
try to play rocket league of course
overwatch i'm gonna do a full gaming
review so if you want to see that
subscribe right now so you don't miss
out all right here we are so let me open
up the settings and let's see
what we got going on graphics currently
have 1080p 16x10 refresh rate set to 120
vsync is off in the advanced section we
have a lot of this stuff turned down
we're trying to get as much fps as we
can full screen there you go let me
choose one of these cars all right there
we go
we're in grand theft auto 5 in crossover
this is awesome because we don't even
need parallels like we used to and it
looks like we're getting decent fps
not getting those weird stuttering drop
frames everywhere this is actually nice
and playable
on one of these new
m1 max macbook pros look at that nice
and smooth yeah this is actually really
good this is at least 60
definitely above 60 fps
and that's the beauty of crossover 21
because
it has the best performance this is much
better than in parallels
and it's also
in parallels and it also doesn't require
you to do a vm or anything in windows 11
just work straight from mac os
which is awesome and there you go grand
theft auto 5 running just fine through
crossovers and the fans aren't even on
which is the beautiful part about these
new macbook pros they're just so cool
and efficient we don't have to deal with
the loud fan noise so there you guys go
hopefully you enjoyed these tutorials on
how to run parallels and crossover for
gaming on these new macbook pros if you
enjoyed the video go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for a lot more
macbook pro content coming up very soon
be sure to check out one of those two
videos right over there once again
congratulations matthew on winning our
giveaway thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]